good morning from Stanford to wherever
you are in the world thank you for being
here today part of the women rise
Community I'm Robin Woodman and I am
here with Dr Sherry Shepard thank you
for being here today she is a professor
emerita of the mechanical engineering
department here at Stanford and her
building is just right across the street
so this was really we're neighbors yeah
we're doing something a little bit fun
today where we're going to be in the
same room thank you for being here great
and she's going to talk to us about her
journey up the obstacles that she had in
making tenured professor some of the
maybe the traps that she had to overcome
um and I like to call it the story
behind the story and it's always so nice
when people can come and share that with
us so thank you so much for being here
today thank you Robin and it's great to
be here but I actually want to actually
be here so I'm going to ask all of you
to indulge me as we start and I'd like
all of you to be here and I suspect that
you've had a busy morning you've maybe
had several meetings maybe you've gotten
kids off to school so indulge me in
helping helping me do some big breathing
so get comfortable maybe put your feet
flat on the floor and we're going to do
some blue jay breathing okay so let's
all take a big breath in
a big breath out
let's do two more big breath in
big breath out
in
out
thank you now I feel like I'm here Robin
so thank you so it is really great to be
here to talk a little bit about
um this idea of being alone or are you
alone in your work and the yes trap so
those are the the two themes that I'm
hoping we'll have some time to discuss
and I urge you as I go along if you've
got questions or you've got comments
please add them in in the chat that is
available to you
um so in some ways my career has been
very much Alone
um you know for 18 years I was the only
women woman Professor on the faculty
from 1986 and then 18 years later we
finally hired another woman to be on the
team and now we actually have seven
women on the faculty in most of my
engineering classes in the 1970s I was
the only woman in the class and I never
had a female professor in any of my math
or engineering courses
um and I you know I could focus on that
but I'm not going to because I'm going
to really talk about some strategies of
getting through that I would say when I
enter a room I still though look around
and scan who's in the room and how many
women are at the table how many people
of color are at the table how many
people with disabilities so that issue
of of how do we increase diversity and a
sense of belonging are still very much
part of my Personal Agenda but also my
professional agenda
so I'm going to talk about you know this
process of not feeling Alone by team
building and so I'd like to introduce
you to three of the teams that have been
particularly important to me along the
way and I hope that as I talk about this
idea of a team that gets you thinking
about whose team are you on or who's on
your team in these three particular
categories and so first I'd like you
like to introduce you to this team and
you'll see three characters here this is
Mrs Miller this is Homer Shepard and
this is professor karagian and they are
I'll call them team career and um let me
tell you a little bit of the stories of
these three people so Mrs Miller was my
violin teacher from the time I was in
seventh grade until 12th grade and um
and from her I really learned what it is
to work hard you know what does it mean
to take something that at first you're
not very good at and then work and work
and work with feedback on getting better
at it and and I think that was the first
time I recognized that that being good
at something isn't just a natural act
you're not just born knowing how to do
something but but with Direction and
dedication you can get good at something
and and that was actually a very
prideful field that I was good at
something it also set my sights on maybe
being a professional musician as a
career and you know what would it be
like to play Bach or Beethoven or Brahms
you know in Carnegie Hall and I have to
say I was also drawn to the idea of
being able to wear elegant gowns and and
um have fancy hairdos and and that that
could be my career path so
um Mrs Miller was key in many ways in
thinking about my career team
the second person is Homer Shepard who
um happens to be my father and um he is
an engineer or he was an engineer he
passed away a few years ago and
um you know he influenced me because I
really admired how he thought you know a
problem would come up in the house and
it could be a broken dishwasher or a
dilemma in the yard and his approach
wasn't to panic you know it was maybe to
say a swear word but then he really got
into a strategy of decomposing what was
wrong you know let's let's look at the
symptoms and let's have a theory and how
do we put that together to maybe puzzle
through what might be happening
um you know at that point I said
engineering though is not for me my dad
worked in a Foundry and if you've
visited a Foundry it's a very noisy
messy hot sweaty environment certainly
not where you could wear elegant gowns
um and so I really wasn't thinking about
engineering but I did admire and start
to recognize that ways of thinking are
important and Engineering had something
to it so that's the second person on my
my team the third is a professor um
courageian
um who was one of my professors when I
was working on my master's degree in
engineering so somehow I did pivot from
music to uh to engineering and I was
working on this Masters because I
thought it was a step to becoming a CEO
of Chrysler Corporation where I happened
to be an engineer at the time and really
seeing more technical depth was
important I was also thinking about
enrolling in an MBA program thinking
again if you want to rise in an
organization you know you need to
understand even more than the technical
about what a business is and I saw in
Professor courageous someone who was so
dedicated to his mission for teaching
and he wasn't simply going into a
classroom and delivering material to
people but in fact he was making that
material come alive to individuals and
so it really planted the seed of saying
is there are there other ways for me to
be in the in the world besides being a
CEO of a company
um he took me under his wing in terms of
helping me write or co-authoring with me
at my first technical paper and he
suggested ah they need some teachers at
night at Lawrence Institute of
Technology you might be good at teaching
and so he put that seed in me of
thinking about teaching so I won't tell
you how that mix of that team came
together in my mind at various stages of
my career to influence where I ended up
being for the last 36 years but I will
leave you with a little teaser about
team career and that's Gertrude
um so Gertrude is a member of my life
and I can tell you the story of Gertrude
and the role that she's playing or how
I'm playing her in my life now
um even though I'm not a professional
musician okay so that's the first team
um the second team I'd like to talk with
you about is
well and actually actually you know one
of the things to to leave you with too
uh is you thinking about who is on your
career team
um and you know how has that changed
over the years and what has been the
influence of those individuals as you
think about steps or stages of your
career
so my next team is the team you go girl
um and um members of that team are
Grandma Joe
Grandma Whitaker and Simona Frank and so
let me tell you the stories of Grandma
Joe Grandma Whitaker and and Simona
Frank and I would say as a team they
really Illustrated to me there's no one
way to have a happy life and to be a
person a woman who is having influence
on the world and that you don't have to
follow set rules because it's not clear
what those rules are so Grandma Joe
um
um you know didn't follow rules you know
she stayed up until the wee hours of the
morning to be making things she was
forever making things
um she didn't like housekeeping and so I
really as a kid looked at her house as
this amazing Museum where you could
touch stuff you know because most
museums you can't I now realize she
probably was a borderline hoarder
um and she didn't like to cook while she
did except when she cooked she would
cook large amounts of food so she didn't
have to cook but one time a week she
also had a trunk of her car that was
filled with picket signs because she was
a devoted devoted to Union and workers
rights so I really saw her passion
coming out in that way so so she was one
of my goatee girl team the other was my
other grandmother who you could say was
in some ways very much a contrast she
didn't like to cook either so much in
fact often went out to restaurants or we
ate deli sandwiches when we visited with
her but she was one of the few medical
doctors in the country in the 1920s
so she went the route of medical school
and uh practiced until well until the
1970s and so she was really a model of
of a woman taking a path that wasn't a
common path and in fact in the little
town where she and my grandfather
um set up their practice in Southeast
Missouri
um many of the citizens of the Town
thought she was a witch doctor and so
really couldn't believe in fact that
that she was um was a doctor and I would
hear her talking with her patients and I
really saw kindness and professionalism
and really a incredible professional
woman doing her work that was sometimes
ignored or pushed back on by the people
that she was trying to help so she's the
second member of my go you go girl team
the the third member is um my my sister
Simona Frank
um who's who's 13 years older than I am
and I should tell a little bit about
about history here so my sister was
going to high school
um in roughly 19
um 61 is when she graduated I graduated
from high school in
1974 and if you're aware of history that
was a pretty pivotal um era in the
United States in terms of women's rights
and and an agenda expanding what what
women could be doing
um Roe v Wade was in the early 1970s
Title IX
um which we've been celebrating was also
in the early 1970s so my sister was
coming of age at a time when when there
hadn't been these expanded rights
um and and access to things but that
didn't stop her um my sister and
graduating from college took on a job
that no other woman in the country had
taken on on she was with a team of four
other women that became Bank examiners
for the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation which is a branch of our U.S
government and so I saw in in this
individual who I love and love dearly
someone who was doing things that were
not conventional too you know in taking
on roles so um so that's that's the go
girl team that has influenced me and
just as a little bit of of History too
um so this this is an ad that IBM put
out and I'll tell you the year in just a
minute but you see some pink booties and
some blue booties and it says
um as things stand it doesn't take much
guess to which one of these will grow up
to be an engineer because by and large
he is encouraged to excel in math and
science she isn't whatever the reason
for the just discrepancy the cost to
society is enormous because it affects
women's career choices and limits the
contributions they make can make only
four percent of all Engineers are women
only 13.6 percent of all math and
science phds are women and an
encouraging but still low 31.3 percent
of all professional computer programmers
are women I have to say and I'll tell
you the year that this this came out as
an ad and it was a gift from my dad
actually to me
um we are up to about 15 of all
Engineers being women so the number has
risen from that four percent
unfortunately the number of people women
in computer science has fallen from 31
so so that that's a declining number
um I am happy to report that there is
now more social science and some of the
work I do actually is in this field for
us understanding why there is this Gap
and what things need to change about the
system in order to encourage more women
to become engineers so this came out in
1985 this ad of IBM saying um this is an
important area for us to be working in
um and it still is
so that's my second team
um okay so let me introduce you to my
third and final team
that I'm going to talk about and that's
team kindness and it's made up of Bernie
Roth and Ruth Shepard you might suspect
that she's my mom she is and
um Ed carrier so let me tell you
um what what that team has been like so
Bernie Roth is a dear colleague and
friend
um and has been since my first day of
Stan stepping on to the Stanford campus
some 36 years ago and a lesson for from
Bernie about kindness is is kindness
really needs to at first and and
foremost be directed inward too you know
I think sometimes we're awfully hard on
ourselves and not really candid with
ourselves and so and so that kindness to
ourselves is important and for me with
Bernie that was for instance is inviting
me to a yoga class some 20 years ago and
I had not done yoga as a girl from
Wisconsin and and Michigan and that's
really become a self-kindness that I
practice maybe not every day but quite a
few days of the week in terms of taking
care of myself both mentally and and
physically another kindness from Bernie
is actually being quite candid with
myself and and learning to be honest
about why I'm doing something why I'm
not doing something and and really not
to quote Bernie not bullshitting myself
about my reasons for doing things and
you know I learned this through a series
of workshops that I attended that Bernie
happened to be one of the co-leaders on
I've also learned it time and time again
with his book which I highly recommend
it's called the achievement habit stop
wishing to start doing and take command
of your life by Bernie Ross so
um kindness starts at home and starts
with us as as individuals just to give
illustrate just a little bit of Bernie's
philosophy so this is a little card he
gave me at some point
and um on decision making and it says
are are you happy and it says yes if
that's the way you're going and it says
well then keep doing what you're doing
and then the other path is are you happy
no
um and then it says here
um change something or no it says do you
want to be happy that's the next
question you know you're not happy is it
important to be happy and if you say
um do you want to be happy no you just
keep doing the things you want to be
doing but if you want to be happy you
change something and so that's kind of
one of the the backbones if you will of
his book here
um so that's Bernie the self-kindness
um from my mom really recognizing that
that kindness can happen in very very
small ways you know with our
interactions with other people and and
maybe it's holding a door open or or
sending somebody after they've given a
talk boy that talk was really great
thanks for giving it
um in my mother's case it showed up in
her 30 years of teaching you kind of see
I ended up doing a lot of what my
parents did an engineer and a teacher
but it wasn't the original path
she would every night when her fifth
graders left she would be at the door
and she would Shake individual hands and
say Miss Smith or Mr Jones have a good
evening I look forward to seeing you
tomorrow I hadn't realized how how
important that little kindness was until
after she passed away a few years ago
one of her former students who was
probably my age said that made the
difference in him having confidence to
survive fifth grade and actually go on
and become a doctor so we don't know how
those little kindnesses impact one
another
so that's a lesson for my mom on on
kindness I would say from the last
character that that's on my go team at
carrier
um Ed's also I'm I'm we're married and
we've been married for 44 years so a
long time and I think the lesson there
is that um kindness never goes out of
fashion
um you know even with somebody that
you've known for a long time and you
really can let your hair down
um those kindnesses remain important and
and whether it's a it's a choosing Diet
Coke instead of Diet Pepsi because you
know that's what he likes and and is
available or leaving a little um a mint
on on the pillow and um just a lot of
little things that that our kindness is
that that do accumulate so on on that
team you know I would ask you to think
about what kindness is and maybe you
already received today what kindnesses
have you extended to others and and how
does that come into your everyday
practice
um with the go girl team you know a
question I should have put out there
would be
um whose goal go girl team are you maybe
on
um and who's on your go go girl team
um so I should say some caveats with
these teams
um some of these characters have
actually been on various parts of these
teams so they're not exclusive teams
um there are also of many many other
people who are on these teams so that
they're not all just three-person teams
um some living some not living some
younger than much younger than I am some
much older than I am
um and I suspect that when you think
about what are the teams that are
important to you they may fall into
these three categories but there may be
other categories so for instance I also
have a team spiritual and that's the
team you know that really helps me think
about those bigger loftier questions or
the meaning of My Life
um and and God and and what role does
God play
um and I also have an exercise team you
know beyond my doing yoga that gets me
out there hiking
um when I think I'm too busy
um so really be also thinking about
what are your teams and whose team are
you playing on
so that's the team part of it like what
do you want to talk about Robin or what
Sherry I've been coming in I love that
we have so many great questions and I
really loved how you divided that all up
and I really love team kindness team
kindness was so great especially
um with Bernie Roth so Bernie's a
fixture over in the d-school what a
lovely human being I've gotten to
interact with him a few times and every
time it's just a pleasure and a joy yeah
um so I really like that Bernie's advice
was be kind to yourself first because
that's where it all begins yeah yeah so
thank you for that so we have some great
questions it looks like Sandra has asked
a really great question she said what if
you were alone and you don't have
support where are some places maybe that
you could look for your team have you
had some experience with you've
um found your team or maybe some
sponsorship or or mentorship that maybe
could answer Sandra's question yeah um
you know I think I think they're looking
for um certainly actually reaching out
and attending this webinar is is a good
starting point of of looking at what
resources there are there's also you
know Finding like interests you know and
it could be hiking you know and and and
actually seeing where the
non-professional can also be
professional links
um you know going to women's events
um for instance tonight we're hosting um
I'm I'm uh The Faculty advisor for a
group called The Emmy women's group and
it's um a club if you will or an
organization a graduate student women in
the department that's been around for 25
years and we're hosting a welcome
reception for alumni from the me
Department as well as all of the
graduate student women in the department
so be looking for those sort of events
um that that are happening um do you
have any thoughts for her too I think
that's I think that's great advice and I
really like the advice of not only
looking professionally and try not to
Silo those and make those in you know
discrete buckets but if what you enjoy
doing outside can also Traverse over to
what you enjoy doing professionally
looking for groups I totally agree with
you and then also I think that there's
something that maybe we get trapped in
ourselves a lot and we're in our heads
and we're ruminating a lot on things and
nine times out of ten the people that
are around you the women that are around
you are having those same thoughts that
you are having and sometimes it's about
just extending the first word yeah um hi
I'm you here or I'm not really sure how
to do this but
um I'm I'm getting used to it or just
having that first word towards someone
could really start that bridge building
that bridge in a really big way you know
it also reminds me of a technique that
we um we teach in a series of classes
called designing your life and there's a
designing the professional that I was
originally part of the teaching team on
and we we teach in that information
interviewing and you know this sense of
of reaching out to someone to say you
don't know me your life looks
interesting can I have 15 minutes of
your time to talk about you and it's
amazing how people are very receptive in
talking about themselves absolutely part
of my reasons for saying yes to this we
love that you want to talk to you about
yourself thank you
um and and you may get some no's but
that people like to feel like they have
something to give absolutely so um it
you know even for Stanford students
sometimes that's a big step to say you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna email somebody
and will they get back with me or I'm
going to try to call them yeah putting
yourself out there in that way yeah yeah
I totally agree I think that's great
advice and you know it it builds on what
you were saying of going in with this
I've got questions yeah yeah and it's
and it's great and it's okay and it's
not a sign of weakness in fact I think
it's a sign of courage to be able to be
able to say that that reminds me you
know the reaching out um I had not been
in in this role very long of it being an
assistant professor and I had the
experience every time I would go into my
chair's office I would come out and go
to the bathroom and cry oh and and you
know I'm thinking nobody else has this
you know and and this experience well I
was at a conference um soon after that
and I was going up the elevator with
another assistant professor who I
admired very much I knew I knew her and
I said to her Pam do you ever cry she
goes
I do it all the time and we were like we
hugged one another because whoa we're
not alone see it's it's about having
that first word yeah oh that's such a
great story thank you so much for that
that's so great to you and I love how
you were so honestly like you didn't
need Peter on the bush do you cry
oh that's so great
um okay thank you so much for that we
have some great questions coming in
um let's see Laura wants to know how do
you represent women in the field of
engineering without getting exhausted is
it just as subversive for a woman in
engineering to just do the work without
always having to represent women oh I I
love this question
um because
um this particularly annoyed me for the
first 18 years as the only woman on the
faculty and and I don't know if I was
projecting but you know I'd be in a
meeting only woman there and people
would ask well what do you think Sherry
and and maybe they were being kind but I
often interpreted it like what's the
woman's point of view here and and I'm
only one woman with one experience yeah
um so that was annoying and it was also
I'd only been here a year or two and and
one of my dear colleagues I think he
thought he was being kind but he asked
what is it like being a woman assist
professor and I was stumped because I
know what it's like being an assistant
professor how being a woman you know
layers on that I'm not sure so yeah so I
I think I said well I can answer the
question about what I'm experiencing as
an assistant professor but but I'm not
sure it's Unique to me being a woman
um so this is where actually getting
colleagues whether they be in the
Sciences or outside can be really
helpful both in sharing the workload of
of if you feel compelled and I certainly
have in my career to be proactive in
saying yes I'm going to do the work and
I see this other burden and
responsibility in figuring out how other
women can be at the table and other
diversity can be at the table
um so so actually building a network of
other people to say could you do this or
I'm going to do this um and and then
even borrowing material and then also
learning some sometimes you have to say
no and then that gets to our second
topic but you know you can't do it all
so you have to preserve that kindness to
yourself in feeling like I've given
enough for right now I can't take on
another speaking engagement or you know
another op-ed article to write
um so that would be you know managing it
by sometimes saying no too
which I think is a great a great thing
to do I think when when we email back
and forth about possibly coming here I'm
always very cognizant of what I'm asking
you know and and understanding that I'm
sending one email with one request but
how many are you actually Fielding yeah
and so it's really important for me to
I I want to extend the grace of saying
it's okay if you if if you can't do it I
totally understand or here's the here's
the ask and and you don't have to put
together a slide deck and yeah it really
just good right oh yeah I mean anything
you want to put a slide deck for I'm in
like call me up
call me up but you know just having
these kinds of conversations and letting
people into the background of what's
going on I think is one of the most
important things that we can be doing I
just I just think it's so helpful you
know I've also recognized that that I'm
not an expert in women's issues I mean
that's not my field of study and so this
is where again connecting with others
has been really important and so you
know a an important colleague for me for
instance is Londa sheebinger who's um
over in the history department and she
looks at design from the perspective of
who's included and who's not included
and and how to develop new guidelines to
be more inclusive and thinking about
design and her website is called
gendered Innovations so you know I I
will pull Londa into my conversation of
like I've been asked to do this maybe
it's better that you do it or do you
have some material that's fresh and new
that I can pull in yeah another really
important um colleague of mine has been
Carol Muller who really knows the
literature on on women and and
engineering and stem fields and and so
relying on Carol if I need to you know
what are some of the most recent
writings that have been happening right
right and that sounds like team
collaboration yeah yes you're right so
we need another team it's always good to
have those collaborators and I think and
I think it's a it's an important
distinction to make just because you you
know you are a woman or we we are women
it doesn't mean we're gonna speak to
everything yeah it just means we can
speak to what your story is or what my
story is yeah and that's pretty much and
I think having that caveat is is a great
distinction to make
um it looks like we had a great comment
here from from kavya thank you for
sharing your various names for your
support groups that makes it easy to
comprehend and realize that we may be
overlooking our cheering Squad and
thinking we don't have one I agree I
mean it's it's great it can come from
anywhere and we need to recognize it and
acknowledge it and let it motivate us
and carry us through our moments of
doubts I just love that concept thank
you and she's going to be sharing it
with her daughter is she starting her
career as a young student which is
exactly why we have these sessions you
know the other thing I realized in
making up this prompt for here this is
going to become a poster on my um in my
office you know both so that my students
see that you know it's not just me
there's other people being represented
here and as a reminder for me because
you know sometimes I have dark days too
and and kind of oh there's a team oh
yeah oh yeah who who is available on the
team today yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely
cool so Sarah had a great question do
you have any advice for raising young
women today
or techniques for encouraging
exploration in stem yeah
um so you know I think
um getting young women
um
making things you know and really using
their hands
um to and and you know making things
ranges from sewing I mean I think sewing
is an incredible activity of going from
a two-dimensional world to a
three-dimensional world and working
inside and outside so in terms of
spatial reasoning it's really great also
though maker spaces and and thinking
about you know what is this electronic
stuff and um demystifying that and you
know I think there are a number of of
camps for instance that Stanford offers
in in the summertime they're also now in
Girl Scouts badges related to Technology
and Engineering so that's another chance
to get get girls involved I would also
say you know I would say and I actually
have a daughter she's 33 and
um she didn't go down the engineering
path she's uh she was a history major
and is the youth librarian in um and the
San Leandro Public Library across across
the bay so she she found her own path
um but exposing girls to making as well
as as what is it to be a modern woman
and that there is that diversity that
includes fancy dresses you know as well
as blue jeans when when things get messy
um you know I think also giving them
um some backbone of when do you push
back when do you also say you know I've
got an opinion here
um how to also and I I think we see this
with our students women students too not
fall into the documentation role in a
team yeah or the planning role and those
are important roles I don't mean to
diminish them but also you know having
them be able to say you know I can write
that code or I don't know how to write
that code but I'm going to figure it out
because that's where I want to expand my
learning so a certain level of I would
say assertiveness
um in all of this yeah absolutely
um something about your daughter being a
librarian I can tell you that the
librarian for me was my hero I loved My
Librarian every year because I was the
kid that I was always reading a book and
it was my Escape it was also my very
safe place and I could just like whip
through them and I would leave the
library with just like stacks and then
the librarian would pull books for me I
just felt so
um
taken care of yeah well it sounds like
similar my daughter had an experience
with her librarian that she had from
Nursery School through eighth a woman
named Misha and Misha would serve tea in
the library too so there was also this
this wonderful Community I would say now
as a librarian though she's also got a
grant and she installed a Makerspace in
the library because really starting to
see how can that place for kids be about
books and about imagination but also
about how do you take that imagination
and use a 3D printer for instance or a
sewing machine to to make it into
hardware and make it into something
tangible yeah that's great so she's
often debugging you know things that
aren't running so so playing the
technology role
as we all do yes
okay um Regina had a really great
question that came in earlier
um I really love your Insight about
needing to see other ways of being and
working in order to imagine those other
possibilities for your future career it
strikes me that not everyone has the
opportunity or opportunities to see what
different careers look like and in
particular women may have less exposure
to traditionally male careers or may not
see themselves in these careers do you
have any tips for how adult women might
get more exposure to different career
possibilities and also what can we do as
adults to expose non-traditional career
paths to more young women
yeah
um you know I I think that's where
um this information interviewing
approach can be helpful you know is is
identifying some domains and this is the
exercise we go through with our students
is is where is a domain that you're
curious about and it may be
um medical Technologies
um or it may be Transportation or it may
be senior care you know that attracts
you in terms of an area that you might
want to imagine yourself working and
then try to figure out who some
individuals are there and and I think
LinkedIn has made this easier in terms
of scouting out who's in what area and
and be bold enough to say you're
interesting can I understand more about
what what you do
um it's probably harder to say can I
Shadow you but really helping them talk
to you about what is your day like you
know what are some of the joys you get
what are some of the hard points
um are there choices that you wish you
had hadn't made you know in terms of
what you're doing what education was
needed what education do you wish it had
you know so so being bold enough to get
out there and ask questions in terms of
Role Models so um one of the things I do
with the Emmy women's group that I
mentioned is we put on a seminar series
every winter quarter called women's
perspectives and it's been around for
about 20 years and um in the fall I sit
down with the leadership the graduate
student women to brainstorm on
interesting people we want to have an
excuse to invite to campus to talk
and we really look at diversity in terms
of of where in the world they're working
what they're working on
um their age you know we have some women
who come who are in their 30s some women
who come that are in their 70s and they
tell pretty different picture different
pictures
um depending on their stage of Life some
who've chosen the academic route some
who've not who've gone to government we
once had a science writer you know who
had done a PhD in mechanical engineering
because like your question implies
people are really hungry for stories and
seeing the diversity of those and seeing
the lumpiness along the way you know so
we tell the speakers just don't make it
all look wonderful because we we really
know you've had some bumps in the road
and you know sometimes speakers will
will talk about depression and needing
to take breaks or along with success
stories so um so we're all hungry for
that
um and and really as a way of trying on
you know that that could be a path for
me or that I don't want to go that way
yeah I think I think also for me a
couple of things are asking people like
what does your average day look like
because sometimes you have in your mind
like what that thing is but then in
reality it's not that thing and some and
if you get too far down that path right
you're like oh I wanna and you know
maybe you heard someone say one day like
oh you're really good at math you should
be an accountant and you don't really
know what else you want to do so you
kind of grab onto that but then you meet
an accountant and it you know if you if
you could meet an accountant and say
what is your average day look like maybe
that's not at all what you want to be
doing and and you know the the physics
teacher might have said to that student
you're good in math do engineering oh
yeah yeah oh yeah 100 and if you don't
have a solid sense of yourself you find
yourself going towards that path of
something that really isn't meant for
you so I think it'd just be no curious
about what comes natural to you
identifying like what you like to do in
a day yeah and then even like going to
LinkedIn like you said or putting in
Google like I like to do this what are
these careers like get basic yeah yeah
you know that's okay and basic and also
open-minded yeah some of those things
could be packaged in in job titles that
you're you're new to you yeah yeah and
it's really a changing landscape in
terms of of skills and how they those
get packaged absolutely and and just
finding other people that have they're
doing things that you like and you look
at their job title like oh that's what
that job title does I mean the question
also brings up this interesting
possibility so I mean with students you
know whether they be undergraduate or
graduate students we we encourage them
to do internships and those are really
trial jobs of you know what is it like
to be an engineer at Boeing or at a
startup or go to a venture capital firm
and you know they can try them on for
three months or six months and then come
back and and and kind of reflect and and
how does that affect their courses and
where else they might want to do
internships
why aren't there adult internships I
don't know Sherry that's what we need
because there's such low stakes way
because I think sometimes people will
get into things and then they're already
concerned about well I I am already here
and I said this but but the internship
is such a finite discreet thing yeah
three months this is what you do and
then you're doing like oh I was like a
little Buffet a little sampler platter
yeah I totally agree let's have an adult
internship
um okay couple more and then we're going
to talk about the yes trap okay
um what are your go-to resources for
designing your life what do you tell
people
uh okay um so one would be read Bernie's
book oh um yep the other is Bill Burnett
and Dave Evans have um two books out on
designing your life okay
um and it is based on on this series of
courses
um that included you know designing your
Stanford experience designing your life
for juniors and seniors to think about
next steps and then we have this version
designing the professional that's for
graduate students and so the those books
really capture a lot of the tools um in
in thinking about what is your world
view you know when you when you write
kind of about your purpose in life and
what you think would be a fulfilling
life is that consistent with writing
your work View and um and so there's
exercises of of writing those and then
then seeing are they consistent with one
another
um there's also this strategy of
information interviewing which I've
already talked about you know where we
get students out prototyping if you will
possible career paths or job domains so
that's another part of it and then the
the course and I their book also gets
this idea of writing an odyssey plan
and not just drawing one of them but
writing three of them and each of them
need to be pretty different and still
encapsulate your work and your world
view and recognizing that there are
different ways to use math in a career
right
um you know it could be as an accountant
it could be as an engineer it could be
as a statistician you know there's lots
of ways to use that skill and and so you
don't feel trapped to say this is the
only path for me and then the exercise
takes what you think is the most
cohesive of those three and actually
write a 10-year plan
um so you can capture a lot of those
exercises in in that in their books okay
great thank you and the one you held up
was the achievement habit by Bernie Roth
okay yeah great yeah excellent thank you
okay good all right let's see
um der Kira said she loves libraries too
so there's again another another plug
for the library and
um Laura just wanted to say thank you
for sharing your story about crying I've
cried in front of every male boss I have
ever had and it took me a long time to
realize it isn't something to be
embarrassed about but it's an
opportunity to normalize the display of
human emotion I'm here for that as well
yeah yeah and I would say I came to the
realization
of not being embarrassed that I was
crying you know that I would actually
cry in front of particularly this one
chair
um and that part of I didn't want to cry
because I didn't want him to feel bad
but I was past worrying about him
feeling bad yeah that's how I felt yeah
yeah yeah I think we spent a lot of time
caretaking other people yeah yeah when
really we should just
yeah cry yeah cry what okay what do we
have we have cry we have adult
internships right right yeah um we have
find your groups right find your people
and and you know reach out to people and
say you're interesting can I have five
or ten minutes of your your time who is
gonna say no to that yeah I agree okay
can you tell us about the yes trap okay
so um you know I want to talk a little
bit about this idea of a yes trap and
and you know I've said yes to many
things in life
um you know I said yes to going down an
engineering path
um I said yes when a group of other
professors approached me in my second
year as a an assistant professor here
and said we're going to put together a
proposal for a grant that's on
engineering education and
um at the time that was kind of a wacky
idea that that research was supposed to
be about technical things my my area of
work was in structures and fatigue and
fracture and welded structures
um so I said yes to that
um and you know I said yes to Professor
couragian about teaching that night
class
and I'm glad I said yes but what I have
gotten stronger believing is when you
say yes what is the no
and so I made a mistake when I said yes
to engineering because I said no to
music
and my conception of Music at that time
is I'm I can do it professionally and
are I'm not going to do it at all so the
yes wasn't a mistake but the no was a
mistake and so I brought Gertrude my
ukulele because I'm back to actually
making music now um after after many
years and um so that no has turned into
a reframed um way of being so that was
too Stark of a no at the time when I was
starting College the second example
about saying yes to
um the colleagues who approached me
about becoming part of this big NSF
Grant
um that my Administration was really
discouraging me from doing saying you
know this this really is not a good
thing for you to do was I did not say no
soon enough to all the other things I
was doing
so for about 20 years I kept a dual life
going of doing research in engineering
education along with doing research on
fatigue and fracture and to be perfectly
honest with you it was exhausting
because I was trying to be a major
player in two different fields and I
wish really wish I had said no sooner
you know after I'd gotten my feet under
me about engineering education to say I
could put that down you know I've done
good work there and I'm moving on to
something else so those are examples of
really needing to think about yes but at
the same time what is what is the no
associated with it you know in in
thinking about also saying yes you know
I recognize I want to make sure that I
get these points that sometimes I say
yes because nobody else volunteers you
know I'll be at a table and you know
somebody needs to organize the next
meeting or write up what we just did or
bring in some other resources or you
know and and I I often after that
awkward pause will say yes because
nobody else is going to do it I
sometimes say yes and I'm recognizing
this because I I confuse quantity of
work with quality of work and maybe
saying more things that I'm doing that
I've said yes to I you know it makes me
feel more important or seem more
important because of all of that yes
that I've done so you know I've learned
to recognize that those are not good
reasons for saying yes to something
um and and Bernie if you read in his
book you know he'll say all reasons are
[ __ ] and that's that's a quote from
Bernie in in here
um I have come up with a strategy though
of a set of questions I asked myself
before I say yes and I've got them
listed here to make sure that um I've
I've got them all and then I'll loop
back to saying why did I say yes to you
um so the first is can I do what is
being asked me
um you know is is it in my my wheelhouse
so to speak of things that that I can do
will I do it you know or will I just let
a deadline pass and and just have said
yes but not actually come through with
with what's being asked
will I be happy doing what is being
asked me and I think that one is
increasingly on my list and and that
happiness includes who am I going to be
working with on this you know are these
really cool people that just there's
going to be joy in hanging out with them
in doing this and interacting with them
um and this one has become more and
Marquee the fourth one is will I be
learning something when I'm doing what
is being asked for me you know if if
it's a
um the same old same old then there's
not going to be a learning opportunity
um there and and I've I've realized that
I'm I'm a learning addict you know that
that idea of of being in a field where I
don't know all of it and and that
messiness of learning is important for
for me in terms of a source of energy
fifth question will somebody else
benefit from my saying yes
um you know so really thinking about a
larger Community graduate students I've
had undergraduates I've had colleagues
and if I say yes to this is it going to
help somebody else's career or pathway
um would somebody else benefit from my
saying no and so recognizing that maybe
that talk that I've been asked to give I
could do it I could learn but actually a
junior colleague might benefit more
career-wise by my saying no in my
recommending them as as a good person to
take it on
and then seventh and this is probably
the hardest one for me that I still
struggle with what will I put down if I
pick this up
so recognizing
um you know getting out by on five hours
of sleep is not a reasonable thing to do
in life by just continuing to pile more
and more on
so going back to your asking me to do
this
um can I do what is being asked of me
yeah I think I can probably talk about
myself
will I do what is being asked for me yes
because Matt Harvey was one of the
people who suggested it and I really
respect my Matt and I'm going to come
through for him you know when he asks
and I say yes will I be happy doing what
is being asking me yes you know Matt is
a fun person to work with and our first
engagements were fun so I thought yeah
I'm going to be happy will I be learning
something new and that one was
interesting because I went back and
looked at the recordings of the the
prior two speakers and I really loved
that each in their unique way
personalized it and it didn't have
PowerPoint slides so for me it was a
challenge of of how to tell my story in
a way that was engaging that brought in
some art you know so so I was learning a
new way of thinking about my story so
that was cool
will someone else benefit from my saying
yes I hope all of you
um and and I've benefited again from
from thinking about how I package or
tell my story in in a different way
um would someone else benefit from my
saying no I actually thought about this
and who else could I recommend
um but decided not because it was kind
of a short time frame and and a lot of
people are busy getting the quarter
started
um and then what will I put down if I
pick this up I have to admit I didn't
put anything down and I had lots of fun
preparing this so it was good oh thank
you I love that checklist and thank you
so much for sure it was nice to see that
in action and kind of how you thought
about it is is you went through it and
now that you have told your story in
this way do you have other opportunities
or applications that you can see this
applying to the telling it this story in
this way yeah yeah yeah maybe for the me
group or maybe for the Emmy maybe for my
um my actually my research team um
because you know there's about 10 people
in that team and they're asking
questions about what's their pathway and
and you know I think I do recognize some
of them look at me out you're the
success successful Professor you've
always been that
um and it may open up a conversation
with them yeah it was not a linear path
at all yeah oh for sure and I think that
a lot of us have that idea in our head
that it's going to look like a certain
way and when it doesn't inevitably look
like that yeah then we're comparing our
insides with everyone else's outsides
yeah
and that's where we cry yeah
absolutely
um let's see a couple of people what is
the book title for Bernie's book it is
the achievement habit yeah the
achievement habit
Bernard Roth yeah
um okay so I think that we have answered
everyone that is that has come in with a
question
um if anybody else has anything else
we'll be around here for a couple of
more minutes
um Sherry that was just great on so many
levels I learned a lot so so selfishly
thank you you're welcome thank you so
much and it's always a great highlight
part of my day when I can sit and have a
conversation with just someone who I
admire and I think is so interesting and
for you to come on and tell your story
behind the story I definitely took a lot
of nuggets from that absolutely and I
saw a lot of overlap too
um so thank you for that and I would say
you know this career path is ever
evolving um you know you you
acknowledged in my title that I've
retired I'm actually on 50 recall for
the next two years Stanford has this
program what does that mean
um that's I'm struggling with that okay
struggling with it in three ways
um it's 50 what's the number you know I
usually work 50 to 60 hours okay so is
it 50 of that or is it 50 of a normal 40
hour a week job so that's the first part
the second struggle is when I figure out
that number what to keep in and what to
put out you know really acknowledging
this is an opportunity to say what would
I like to have stickiness here at
Stanford after I'm gone right so who are
my new partners or who what are
Partnerships I want to strengthen so
that other people are taking things I've
started and continuing them what are
things that only I care about and I
could put them down and no one would
notice
and then what are new things I want to
be taking on that I will continue even
after I'm fully retired so so that's
kind of the second part of the struggle
and then the third part is I realize I
cannot Care at 50 percent
that when I do something I'm carrying a
hundred and ten percent and so really
recognizing with whatever I'm doing that
smaller set that I've got the space to
really put my my heart and soul and
hands into it and and so I think that's
really the hardest one is recognizing
that I care a lot right and since you're
going to Care 110 you need to be
especially specific about what you are
choosing to care a hundred okay yeah
that makes a lot of sense so um so
that's where I'm playing a lot more
music
um you know I'm doing more writing kind
of in the op-ed area you know after a
lot of experiences I've got opinions on
things
um I'm I'm working on on consolidating a
lot of research over the that I've done
for the last 20 years in terms of other
papers or a book okay so so it's it's a
fun stage and a scary stage just think
about what's next right because it's a
stage that obviously you've never been
in before and so now you're you're
figuring it out about what that actually
means and this is where role models for
me have been interesting and I've been
doing a lot of information interviewing
of people who are retired to understand
you know what their lives are like and
you know my colleagues mostly men have
not retired and so their one role model
of you just keep going you keep going
and you keep going
um but I've been reaching out
specifically to women academics who've
retired and and what has their life what
is their life looking like right I think
that's great it's kind of like
it's the later stage of in the beginning
when you're looking at other people and
what they're doing for careers so how
how are you retiring what does that look
like for you
and you may have heard of this idea of
the Encore career
um and you know where you've you've
devoted and been accomplished in one
area and then there may be other things
that that you want to do so this is kind
of funny three three jobs I've been
considering and I know we're almost at
time one is school bus driver
um you know that I think just engaging
with kids every day and and seeing them
not be grumpy but how do you be kind to
them and get them to smile kind of like
your mom yeah yeah so so a school bus
driver another is on the sides of Roads
you see these signs of this part of the
highway kept clean by so-and-so yeah you
know I could be one of those people but
keep you know cleans up that part of the
highway and then a third wild idea is
actually to get an ice cream truck you
know that goes around the neighborhoods
and plays the music and has the kids
come out and I would have really cheap
ice cream like it would be good ice
cream but like only a nickel right and
then I would have a little chair so I
could play my ukulele and have the kids
come and sing Oh that's all right so I'm
having fun thinking wild ideas you could
have like every Tuesday at your
daughter's Library oh I hadn't thought
of see talking to people expands the
ideas yeah there could be like a whole
day like a maker like a maker thing and
then a book and then go outside for some
ice cream and songs with Sherry yeah
sharing Gertrude yes that's awesome
thank you so much for being here okay it
was really fun that was really fun
everyone thank you so much for being
here we really appreciated all your
comments all your questions and being
part of the women rise Community this is
our final live session but they will
live in perpetuity on the page
which you know and love so well
um and you'll be getting a recording of
this session within one week and we just
want to really say thank you so much for
being part of this community and it's
been really great and thank you again
Sherry for welcoming us out and I would
say remember to keep breathing keep
breathing yes right that's right and
it's okay to cry yes okay bye everybody
bye thank you so much